Southern Nevada Health District is of
course playing a huge role in the
state's plans to reopen and a big
question when will casinos be allowed to
open their doors the i-team's vanessa
murphy joins us to tell us what needs to
be done before that can happen
hi Vanessa hi yeah I asked the Health
District when they would consider it's
safe for casinos to reopen they did not
provide a date but they say we are
headed in the right direction the
Director of Community Health is
referring to specific indicators the CDC
and Governor Steve select laid out for
reopening the state which includes
casinos that's a 14-day decline in cases
hospitalizations and hospitalization
stability which he says we appear to be
reaching he says we are starting to see
a plateau and decline in cases the
Health District is working to roll out
antibody testing but dr. Michael Johnson
points to contact tracing and increased
testing so far the more community
testing we do the more cases we're going
to find and that's not a bad thing
because then we can determine who is
positive out there and make the
necessary recommendations and steps to
have themself isolate the treatments
necessary and so on as we've reported
governor sis elect says phase 1 will
begin on or before May 15th and casinos
will not open at the beginning of phase
1 and as the state of Nevada reopens
another topic of conversation these
masks the Health District recommends
people wear them when they go out in
public
dr. Johnson says 80% of cases have mild
symptoms or no symptoms at all a mask
can help protect you and others
reporting live Vanessa Murphy 8 News now